hello everyone thanks for joining or
listening it's November 11th
11 11 22.
and we're in cohort two of the active
textbook group
having a discussion of chapter five
exploring some topics
there are some questions
that have been written in comments as
well
and then
taking it wherever we want as we review
the first half of the book
that'll be today
and then
next week we'll be taking an even
further step back
and more of a focus on like feedback
completing the feedback form
how can we improve and structure future
textbook group cohorts project ideas and
so on
but for today we're in chapter five
so
um
does anyone want to
give any thoughts or comments or just
initial questions to raise about chapter
five
all right then let's go into the written
questions
okay
how does the simple hierarchy with
one-to-one mapping between levels as
shown in the left hand side of figures 4
6.
and 5.2
four six
five two
relate to actual brain hierarchies such
as the classic fellerman and Van Essen
diagram
from retinal ganglion cells up to
hippocampus with many to many mapping
between Regional units
ah
I guess this is the famous
diagram
well what do people think how do these
seemingly
skyscraper like
hierarchical models
this one is laid out side to side but we
can see ascending and descending so this
could have been graphically laid out
like this and then another one and then
a third one on top
of course top down the bottom-up are
just spatial metaphors
so
um
how do we reconcile
computational hierarchical models
with
the empirical structural connectivity of
the brain
which
has
a wiring structure
looking like this
Ali
between these two kinds of icons or
kinds of maps because on one hand we
have a kind of relational map and on the
other hand there is a kind of
architectural slash functional mapping
of the brain so
for example if we look at a circuit map
of the of an electric circuit there's we
have a relational map there right but
when we want to implement that circuit I
mean
in terms of wiring and so on we need to
have another kind of map which is
architectural one
so
of course in some cases there's a
possibility of translating one map
perfectly onto the other but there isn't
necessarily an isomorphism between those
two kinds of map and I think in this
case we don't necessarily see that
isomorphism here as well
excellent great answer totally agreed
these kinds of diagrams are often
described as hierarchical or heterotical
or people use difference
um
words to describe it but it's describing
the anatomical connectivity of different
brain regions
whereas the diagrams that are shown in
these figures that were mentioned in the
question
are not anatomical Regions they're
statistical variables connected by edges
this is the difference between
structural and effective and functional
connectivity structural connectivity is
what pieces are actually put together
and through direct contact
intermediating
whereas
functional connectivity has to do with
the statistical relationships in the
system
and those are not necessarily for a
given set of measurements or spatial or
temporal scale or experimental stimuli
those are not exactly the same thing
there are cases where there are but that
doesn't mean that in general they're the
same thing so how do they relate to
quote actual brain hierarchies
they relate to each other in the way
that Ali just described
similarly between
um uh architectural diagram and a
functional diagram
does anyone have any other
thoughts on this
yeah Giuseppe
yeah I think that is a is a very good
explanation on the other hand I think
that at that stage of the of the
description the idea was to see how
active inference could also provide a
process Theory so basically to to see
how these information mechanism may be
implemented in a neural circuits so
yes the two are not completely the two
descriptions are not isomorphic but I
think there should be some degree of
of uh agreement and
in this case I think that
what may be masking the the the
similarities or the the potential
overlap is that you know there there's a
a big difference in the degree of
complexity of the so one is a very
simple the the active inference diagram
is a very simple sketch of a very simple
micro circuit while this one is a big
architecture with a lot of complexity
and it's difficult to
to go in and say you know
to map exactly those kind of micro
circuits within this large circuit
scheme
it's probably the there's going to be
various
micro circuits in there with the various
degrees of a hierarchical structure
within that
that large scheme I guess
yeah
um all great points
the figures that were pointed to
reflect like just
simple
illustrative examples
whereas the whole brain
or many of the regions of the brain if
one were to even just describe this with
an active inference model it wouldn't
look as simple and narrow as these
previous figures so it's a different
type of diagram it's a different scale
yet
through Visual and prose-based
argumentation
as well as the the hopes and dreams of a
field
is that there is a relationship between
the messages that are passed between
different variables statistically which
as we discussed last time it can you
could arrange these in a hexagon
it wouldn't change the topology and thus
the function of the base graph
however it is being laid out in a
specific way
to demonstrate resonance with
given cellular populations in a cortical
column
so it's kind of
um
situational to what extent the
structural neuroanatomy
aligns with the Bayes graph as specified
but
we can definitely say that they're not
the same thing
that they don't have to be the same
thing
but there's also situations where by
graphical design
using that in multiple ways meaning you
could constrain your construction of the
base graph
such that it has some structural
patterns with the anatomy and then also
just in terms of like visual graphical
design
like you can just lay it out visually
because this is not these are it's not
exactly like there's five and then three
like there's other things that are here
that aren't shown here
so like this is a a course mapping
any other thoughts on this question
asked
uh just really briefly I feel like the
30 million foot view of the like
structural constraints sort of is that
in the general case of a base graph your
well inactive inference we're talking
about like a Markov chain or some
blanket that is kind of ultimately the
state space kind of which is included in
it
um
if you're trying to map that to a brain
or any kind of
system with discrete units that are
close sometimes and not so close then
the arrangement of those will constrain
necessarily the base graph
to some degree
if you if they're right next to each
other
then there's going to be a greater
chance that they are
Independence
some sort of dependency relationship
even if the from like disparate
you know far away neurons are actually
more strongly correlated they will have
to travel through those in some sense
the the network there right
um so
I'm not sure if that's clear but the
what I'm saying is that the physical
proximity and adjacencies in a physical
system kind of
partially correlate to something like a
markup blanket like the constraints the
possible operation in the system
yes it can
and also this was a major Topic in the
recent
51 live streams
like we talked about how different by
like the pomdp structure partially
observable more composition process
structure or just generally the active
Bayesian graph representation of a
generative model
that's not
the anatomy that would carry out that
model
you would need to make a neural network
with a totally different connectivity to
implement that model
and so we discussed how do you get
from
a stated base graph
to a neural network architecture that
carries out that computation
which helps integrate it more closely
with experimental results and also
software packages and different kinds of
computational heuristics
and then how do you get from a neural
network
to a pomdp
and so this Paper 51
establishes this relationship
formally as well as empirically
so it's
extremely important reading slash
listening in the space of beyond the um
more foundational points that have been
made in the last several minutes which
is just simply
these kinds of graphs
are not
that's just two different categories of
visual representations that both use
nodes and edges but they're describing
different things with nodes and edges
and then to go deeper and to understand
exactly how biological and artificial
neural architectures
implements the kinds of generative
models specified by a Bayesian graph
then the paper discussed in 51 is the
most recent and advanced discussion on
it in the field
okay
how are categories actually encoded in
the brain
so can you can you add that reference
there oh sure
thank you
yeah
and they've done work in in silico
in vitro neurons and in Vivo animals it
seems like
so
funny there's fef free energy functional
but it's definitely not that
and there's been other
discussions of just structural versus
effective and functional connectivity in
the brain
all right so how are categories actually
encoded in the brain and Neil added a
comment
I understand that prediction errors are
thought to be encoded as pulse density
I.E frequency modulated Spike trains as
measured on single neurons
this might lead us to think that
categories are encoded in single neurons
like the notorious grandmother and
Jennifer Aniston neurons which are
neurons that have been reported in
different studies to have an increased
and sometimes like specific firing rate
increase for a specific stimuli
so they'll have they'll be measuring
thousands of neurons and some neurons
fire when some image is brighter or
darker and some neurons don't have any
clear relationship with visual input but
then they'll find some neuron that fires
for Jennifer Aniston but not for other
closely related stimuli and so hence the
fame of the Jennifer Aniston neuron
in this schema are we really saying
one as far as active is concerned it
doesn't matter how categories are stored
within a cortical column components
we just need to model that they are with
associate precisions
two we suppose categories are stored
statistically somehow collectively
within a local population of neurons
Would we not expect prediction errors to
be represented in Spike trains on many
neurons coming into or going out of a
cortical column all right there's many
ways to explore this question
who wants to give a first thought
wait on you Ali yeah go for it Ellie
oh well actually it's a very big
question in the philosophy of mind and
the philosophy for cognitive science I
mean the question of how uh brain
represents the uh the signs and the
external objects but
um
one theory is
um basically based on versus the
taxonomy of signs uh I mean as we
um as many were aware uh purse
classifies or the signs into three types
of symbols icons and indices uh but
when we want when we
apply this taxonomy
in the representation mechanism of brain
basically what we need at the very first
as as a very first step is to understand
how the brain represents indices and
icons
as a kind of
representation processes that would need
minimal amount of Consciousness right so
uh for indices and icons uh I mean the
difference between indices and I icons
are that icons are a kind of uh
structural structure preserving maps and
indices uh are uh we in indices we have
a kind of causal relationship between
the signs and their reference so before
uh
um before uh we
um
representing uh the tokens of an object
as an index of an external object we
need to have a kind of map or an icon in
order to map that in that token of index
to our icon right so one theory for
doing that is so-called homuncular
theory proposed by Daniel Dennett in
which he proposes a hierarchy of
subjects with decreasing levels of
consciousness
and on the bottom most level We have
basically non-conscious non-conscious
subject to somehow grasps the icon in
a kind of just a
representational map without uh
interpreting it as a specific
um as a specific Index right but then
again uh it passes that representation
into its higher levels of hormone
homunculus uh with uh increasing their
increasing Consciousness until it
reaches the subject quote-unquote
subject which is basically our whole
mind so yeah it's a very big subject and
of course
it's impossible to summarize it in just
a couple of minutes but I would
recommend a very interesting book on
that subject if anyone wants to further
explore that the the first chapter of
materialist phenomenology by Manuel
enter
explains it with a crystal clear prose
what that kind of representation or how
that mechanism would work
nice
great answers so a few more
angles on this question
um
first the question of representation in
active and in Neuroscience is a large
area
so
for something to be represented
in the brain
it doesn't need to be what it is in the
outside world clearly but that leads to
like a lot of of course
um discussion about how representations
actually do occur in the brain
so the question
um was prediction errors are encoded as
pulse density as measured on single
neurons well the simple answer is it
just simply does not have to be that way
prediction errors in a different
cognitive system or region could be
encoded as the autocorrelation function
of the spike train
or there are neurons that are
non-spiking
or it could be a brain region there's
just no reason to uniquely associate the
conveyance of prediction errors
to the extent that statistical
parameters are even conveyed in
neuroanatomy at all which one doesn't
even have to agree with but to the
extent we're even going to talk about
neural phenomena as being related to to
statistical phenomena
it doesn't have to be the spiking
density
nor does it have to be on single neurons
now that being said
in the neural network
discussion in 51.
there was a relationship that they are
showing between the fast perceptual like
Dynamics and Spike firing rates and the
slower Dynamics and the neural
plasticity of the synapses so as kind of
before like it could be but just because
it could be in in some senses maybe
doesn't mean that those are an identical
mapping
um
then
categories are encoded in single neurons
um well if by that is meant encoded by
firing sensitivities in networks of
neurons
then there is already more being taken
into account it's kind of like figure
and ground it's not like that neuron
taken out of that Network would still
signal Jennifer Aniston the semantics of
a given category
are associated with the inputs and
outputs even in cases where there is a
statistically tight relationship between
the firing activity of some neuron and
some other category being identified
um then
are we really saying
it doesn't matter how categories are
stored we just need a model that they
are so that is an instrumentalist
perspective
which is just saying
whatever the neurological substrate is
of
how categories are enacted and
represented in the brain
we're going to use a specific type of
model
that is super tractable supercomposable
translates across systems and so on
hashtag active
and we're not saying that's the
architecture of the system
so that's an easy instrumentalist
position that can always be taken
and we suppose that categories are
stored statistically somehow
collectively within a local population
of neurons that's an empirical
hypothesis one could test whether a
population rate code
or a area of activity
or other aspects of neural function that
aren't even as commonly discussed
depending on the specific question come
into play
Would we not expect prediction errors to
be represented on Spike trains on many
neurons coming into and going out of
if you expect it if that's your prior
then you expect it if it's not your
prior you don't expect it
there might be anatomical or statistical
reasons
to
scaffold the belief
that there would be a many input many
output system or not
but it can't be answered in the general
those are just the examples of Empirical
neuroanatomical research to actually
pursue
um Brock how do you see it related to
viveki
um I mean relevance realization is uh
uh I mean very roughly like
opponent processing it's I mean it's
I don't I don't really
understand the fundamentals of precisely
how that would work in a
neurological physiological sense
um
but it's kind of again like I guess you
could uh like
yeah the promotions there
um but
um yeah that just that you're
contrasting like different
um fittedness I guess of um
in in the live stream he gave this I
guess example of um like a dog versus a
four-legged animal versus a mammal or
whatever why did they say the dog ran by
sort of thing
um is that that has a good fit
um
and that
realized relevance is somehow related to
opponent processing
um so it's it's that's I guess a way in
which it's related to categories or very
crudely like
General differentiation or something
like this
um
tangentially related I don't know yeah I
don't know it's like a conceptual
approach too yeah there's always
different coarse grainings of categories
that can be appealed to
in speech or in the brain
and so outside of contrived
you know sorting tasks
in the more open-endedness of the niche
that the systems have to engage with
the categorization
[Music]
is has different characteristics
than like a binary sorting task
so that's that's what viviki ties to
relevance
okay
does anyone want to add another question
or thought on five
what other neural systems or behaviors
are people interested in modeling
foreign
but also in that in that uh diagram
behind the
window there there's goals
Golds yeah where did those come from
seems like um
I guess you could do planning without
goals but it seems like goals a goal
there would be a
kind of a reason to plan to get a
biological goal of like
homeostasis right lsasis is sort of this
sort of
there was a live stream you guys did
recently on that right
and then
some more subjective cultural thing yeah
I don't know
yeah well here
um with the more narrow
goal interpretation
the difference is between the direct and
the indirect policy selection Pathways
in the stratum which is mediated by
gamma
the dopamine signaling
and so here on this left side
the habits dominate policy selection
so e represents the affordances but it's
not just like affordances are not just
like yes no in the E vector
they represent
the prior probabilities of given actions
so where an affordance is impossible it
is given a prior probability of zero and
therefore it's never selected
where the prior probability on some
action affordance being engaged in is
high
it's more likely to be undertaken so e
is not just like a list
of what you can choose from it's not
like a menu It's like a menu of actions
that's weighted by habit
in this Construction
and so
in the absence
of any kind of pragmatic or epistemic
value which is to say free energy
minimization
Behavior recapitulates The Habit
so there's a mode of policy selection pi
where the entity is merely
recapitulating
probabilistically
their history and habits
that's shown on the left side of the
stratum
then the right side of the stratum
shows the cortical engagement
of
seemingly more goal directed whether
pragmatic goal directed and or epistemic
goal directed
or as we think about it in active
inference them the pragmatic and
epistemic integration
into a single imperative G
like
um let's just say I usually walk up and
down but I rarely go left and right and
I'm in a maze
this left mode
of policy selection is just going to be
recapitulating the decisions previously
made
the right mode is going to ideally
strike a balance between pragmatic and
epistemic value
but any discussion of pragmatic and
epistemic value so pragmatic value
bringing alignments reducing the
Divergence between your preferences and
observations
getting what you want getting what you
expect
an epistemic value reducing your
uncertainty gaining information
any discussion of the relative merits of
different policies
in terms of their expected free energy
which again is to say they're relative
or
relative pragmatic and epistemic value
any evaluation of policy
is a different cognitive and
computational process
than merely the recapitulation of habits
which doesn't require any consideration
of policies at all
so this is kind of like walking forward
walking into the future
looking backwards
I mean in some deeper sense aren't we
always
but this e-mediated mode of decision
making
does not require any evaluation of
counterfactuals or comparison of
alternative outcomes
now where do habits and preferences come
from
because if under G the pragmatic value
is going to be associated with
prior probabilities on preferences
and um epistemic information as well is
going to be mediated by priors which
here are being shown as kind of
cortically embodied
where do those parameters come from
Evolution ecology development and
behavior over different time scales
so the coarse grained priors are
inherited
through the process of evolution
and then finer and finer scale
adjustments can occur
via ecological and developmental
processes
culminating in learning
and at the very fast scale perception
that's the deflationary approach which
would be Evolution has put all those
tested processes Evolution ecology
development Behavior learning and then
perception
put that entity's generative model in
the context of a generative process
into
an Adaptive position
if it's not adaptive that far from
equilibrium system is going to quickly
dissipate you just saw something in its
last day
or it's not its last day and then the
inference is going to continue Giuseppe
yes
[Music]
something that is not too clear to me
habits are supposedly supposedly they do
refer
uh to things that are learned during the
lifetime of the agent
um
as opposed to being a
deposited through Evolution for instance
because one could say also that the the
the policies with high pragmatic values
that that are the one that preserve the
phenotype of the agent are kind of
habits but they pertain to the longer
time scale of uh phylogenesis so to say
so
so is there
the distinction here
like the specific of habits the
characteristic of web is is that they
have been learned they they are they
come from a statistical regularities
that have been uh accrued and
represented through the lifetime of the
agent to the experience of the of the
agent
I believe that it doesn't have to be
only learned during the lifetime like
let's just say that there's a species of
bird that flies at night
it habitually flies at night
and then you can zoom in more and say
now within that bird species they're the
early risers and the late risers
and this one is habitually Rising early
and that one's habitually Rising late
now that may be a genetic polymorphism
that doesn't even have to be learned at
all
so I think of course in humans we take a
very developmental learning based
approach towards the habits and you know
Aristotle you know Excellence is what we
repeatedly do and all of that but when
we just think about habit as what is
habitually done then it's a little bit
clearer that it's not necessarily
learned
but then once you couldn't you
subsume the
like the the tendency to fly more at
night as a as a preference that is
within
the
[Music]
within the
yeah as a preference like within the
same Matrix
yes and in some
um convergent evolution scenario
we would see the Habit distribution
recapitulating the preference
distribution increasingly mindlessly
offloading the cognitive work of
evaluating policies
and reducing Divergence through free
energy minimization
we might expect some of that
to become habitualized
and merely reflected through the
affordances that can be taken or the
probability of different affordances in
terms of their prior preferences or
prior probabilities on affordances
um rather than needing to be mediated
through preference that's one answer and
another kind of corollary answer is on
one hand we can talk about preferences
over any distribution
but in the bird example
um
the preference for flying at night might
not be a category that's accessible to
it
but
preferences
that have to do with um
the amount of photons being detected
might interact synergistically with
habits around like a circadian rhythm or
habits around flapping your wings
like once the wing is flapped up it
always flaps down
that doesn't even need to be
computationally modeled as a policy
decision
because it could be relying on these
regions of the brain or these kinds of
pathways
that don't explicitly consider
alternatives in the same way
and I think again as we discussed at the
beginning this isn't the literal
interpretation of the neuroanatomy but
it's kind of showing two extreme
um ends of a continuum
with
um the least to the most explicit
consideration
of future policies
with all the pros and cons of turning
the volume up turning the volume down
and the volume is computationally
analogous to the role of dopamine
signaling in the striatum
and in insects Ollie
uh yeah and uh another slightly
different take on this subject is laid
out by J Scott Kelso in his book Dynamic
patterns the self-organization of brain
and behavior uh in which uh he says that
because uh the state of uh all the
possibilities are too complex to be
calculated at each um at each time and
for each decision
he uh he lays out something like this
that if we look at it and look at the
state of the possibilities
um in terms of its uh distribution of
singularities and the basins and The
Well of those singularities or or the
attractors of uh the Basin of attractors
the policy making can be achieved by uh
by the effect of the param by the effect
of adjusting the parameter and the
proximity of those Wells or basins so
for example
manipulating that parameter parameter to
make some wells or basins shallow with
the result that the associated preferred
state becomes less stable so in this
condition random fluctuations actually
can spontaneously somehow dislodge the
system from a data space that estate and
push it into another state so in this
case
The Habit can also be explained by the
varying degrees of these kind of
parameter adjustments throughout all the
state of possibility States
awesome yeah
yeah this is this is
very interesting one one subject in
which I'm
[Music]
I'm interested in applying uh the active
inference framework is uh on a
meditative practice and actually it has
been one proposal is that
it may work exactly like that so that uh
the the tractors that are very deep and
um and are firmly Consolidated through
habits through meditative practice
becomes shallower also that the
range of possibilities of
behavior and perception becomes larger
because you you you you are not
constrained by this deep Wells of uh of
uh of energy that have been established
through your habits but the interesting
thing here the Intriguing part is that
through a very
uh
repetitive practice kind of repetitive
practice you are you some how make your
uh energy landscape more shallow at
least at least
at least during the practice so it's a
it's an interesting this paradoxical
aspect how you
you could somehow
train with the very habitual practice to
weaken your habits
oh just extremely not of a tangent here
but
it's totally interesting and one could
imagine
um
real practices or simulated
computational agents that engage in
repetitive actions and that just
sharpens it doesn't open their mind a
lot of meditation is not about expanding
one's mind or changing one's Behavior
it's actually about converging to
a certain regime of attention
and sharpening distributions that exist
during the practice and after the
practice
there are other cases where we can
modulate our receptivity
through repetitive actions
and being exposed to just merely novelty
all the time doesn't necessarily
breed novelty in US it might just
confuse us
mm-hmm
yeah
yeah Brock some habits are reciprocally
narrowing some are reciprocally opening
yeah
yeah they can look very similar
and without
um the ability to see the cognitive
states of another
if somebody's just sitting quietly
maybe they're narrowing maybe they're
opening maybe they're
sleeping
well to your point you mean about you
know like some basic version of
meditation of just like focus on your
breathing
was like sharpening and narrowing it but
in doing that
over time you kind of grow this capacity
to modulate your attention more
on other things more intentionally right
um so
right probably not
perhaps this idea that by doing that by
deploying attention more on the sensory
aspect you kind of avoid a little bit or
bias the usual drift of precision
upwards toward more like Superior layers
of the hierarchy associated with mind
wandering Etc
so this
wrong one would you like to add anything
okay
awesome I'm going to copy your comment
in so we can read this
I would put forward here the practice of
Alexander technique where we optimize
Precision by repetitive action I.E
getting in and out of a chair whilst
inhibiting and directing
hmm
yeah it'd be interesting to
[Music]
um
with this three
region neuroanatomical model
yeah
Oracle
the most cognitive most semantically
accessible
the midbrain striatum
most dopamergically associated with this
um Continuum between habitual and goal
directed policy selection and then
action mediated in the peripheral
nervous system through
um Divergence minimization
and then
sketch out
I'm sure
and then sketch out yeah like um in the
Parkinson's case where there's a loss of
dopaminergic signaling
um which can in the extreme lead to like
failures of initiating and planning
action
and then
um there was a
um
thank you
Robin Williams movie
Awakenings
this movie is about a uh early on
Oliver Sacks wrote that book but then
there's a Robin Williams movie
and um there was a floor of patients in
a Medical Institution
who were all suffering from basically
these different symptoms that today
could be recognized as like hypo
dopaminergic
um
signaling and then
the doctor goes to a conference learns
about l-dopa which is like a pre a
metabolic precursor of dopamine so
dopamine does not cross the blood-brain
barrier in mammals however l-dopa does
and um
then that like awakens people but it
shows
um
like some of the motor and cognitive
consequences of hypo and Hyper
dopaminergic signaling
um one question for me is where does
reasoning fit into thicker 5.5
the gears of thought
where's the transmission in the
carburetor
like those are great
questions so there's probably many
different
um
angles to take on it
one
angle is like reasoning is a a synonym
of inference
and so by pointing to reasoning
we are talking about
families of inferential structures
and so depending on what that reasoning
is about
it could manifest in different ways
and so like yeah Ali
actually helmholz proposes that
reasoning can as you said it can be it
can be done also unconsciously as
inference so uh actually one of the
starting points of this whole area
Bayesian brain hypothesis and probably
its origin is uh helmholtz essay I
forgot its exact name from 1866 or
something in which he proposes a theory
of unconscious inference or unconscious
uh conclusion uh in which uh sometimes
reasoning actually most of the time the
majority of our reasoning processes are
not done in our conscious levels so uh
yeah I also agree with you that
reasoning can be taken as a synonymous
for these kind of inferences as well
yeah but like on the experiential
side it is so
fascinating and mysterious
stimuli are presented
certainly there are
um unconscious inferences that
facilitate even the initial
understanding of a stimuli
like a visual stimuli like seeing a
letter as a letter
seeing a handle for grabbing is kind of
the ecological inactivist angle
but seeing a symbol or sign and that
kind of invokes what Ali described
earlier with the theory of semiosis
but then
we wait
and we feel like we reason
and we
make decisions
and so how to
[Music]
um
how to square the graphical models
of inference which is to say reasoning
with that yeah Brock
I was just gonna ask I guess where
mental action fits into this on policy
selection or habits or goals like
yeah yeah
like um I yeah I I think the vast
majority of this is yeah that you get
like this base
unconscious inference but at some point
it feels like there's something
conscious there about selecting between
two things sometimes
it really
intentional and
thinking real hard
um so I wonder what that is I guess
yeah
Giuseppe
something about going back to habits
something that I just thought about
um so usually habitual actions from the
point of view from the psychological and
phenomenological point of view are
they seem to require
much less mental energy or psychological
energy so we can think about that in
terms of uh you know the theory of
system one and system two like by then
economy and
I wonder if they're seeing they seem to
have some preferential uh low levels of
of free energy also of expected free
energy uh the police the habitual
policies compared to other policies that
somehow
mirrors there
they're relatively low investment of
energy psychologically
yeah well that's been
a hotly debated topic
and one of the most mystifying
observations
is that the brain does not change in
metabolic activity greatly
depending on the task and so there's all
these amazing analogies between Freud
and free energy and all these things
that Psalms and fristians and others
have worked on and of course the
tantalizing connections between free
energy minimization and energetic
um balance
and the um fmri signal that's being
studied is the brain oxygen levels
changing bold signal and also people can
study the glucose metabolism
but these levels of change
are very small
in brain metabolism and glucose usage
and they're not simply associated with
like quote thinking hard and even
necessarily cognitive demands
and so it's it's like it's like a I
don't know if it's a hammer without a
nail or a nail without a hammer because
empirically it doesn't change in energy
use that much
although although there was a recent
paper
and I think it's in
it's on a big Journal I can't remember
if it's nature or
or actually
it was
um
there was you know they proposed some
[Music]
some kind of uh
approach similar to energy minimization
and and that they were showing that
actually the
the energy
spent in in synaptic communication was
was uh minimized and if I I may look for
it and I may post it here
um
but I wonder more specifically
in this in this idea of that habitual
patterns of behavior or let's say
sequences of action gets shifted with
practice to being process from the
cortex to the basal ganglia
somehow there is uh there is actually
[Music]
well not not only not only like a
metabolic energy like in terms of
glucose or Advantage but also in terms
of uh really free energy so
I don't know if that has been looked
at
uh specifically like for the basal
ganglia or I don't know there must be
something because
it does seem that
uh
mental resources at least experientially
are become much
[Music]
the requirement resources become much
less once
once you a task is automatized let's say
yes just shortly to close this and and
to address this uh
final question when does passive become
active inference and end planning well
we could look at from a base graph
perspective is action involved
if the task is merely perceptual we can
say that it's passive inference
if ocular motor cicading is required so
even if the person's in a chair but
they're moving their eyeballs that could
still be modeled as active inference and
you'd want then a unified imperative
for inference and action
and then when is it planning well as we
had some controversial discussions on in
cohort one about the second half of the
book is it really planning do we really
see planning in this textbook
um as if planning would be behavior that
looks like it's enacting a plan like a
chess player who's winning a game but
the strict and narrow definition of
planning might be explicit consideration
of sequential actions and their
consequences
and preparation for those in evaluation
of them
and free energy reduction or
minimization could be used in purely
passive inference which is where it's
widely used in general
as an Evidence lower bounds and in
machine learning without action in the
loop
so the innovation of active inference is
to bring action into the fold of
inference
and make a unified free energy
functional imperative
for perceptual learning and action
inference
all right
hope it's okay we went a few minutes
over but thanks
cohort 2
next week we return
for some overview and debrief look at
the project ideas
and also look forward to Future textbook
groups so feel free to fill out the um
feedback form and encourage others to do
so as well and also take a look through
some thoughts and add more thoughts on
future groups which we'll go over next
week so thank you talk to you soon